Hello, and welcome to my session, cluster API
as code.
My name is David McKay,
and I am a CNCF ambassador
and senior developer advocate for Equinix Medal.
And I am from Glasgow in sunny sunny
Scotland.
I have a menagerie of animals in my
office.
I have chinchillas, taggers, a ferret, and a
dog.
I'm also a prolific livestreamer, streaming multiple times
per week,
trying to cover all of the cloud native
landscape technologies.
Hopefully, providing learning materials so we can all
learn together.
And, of course, I'm also supporting my wonderful
COVID hair. You're welcome.
And I am definitely a member of the
Pineapple Pizza Club.
So let's get started.
So what is Cluster API project?
Well,
it is a sub project of Kubernetes
that aims to commoditize
the creation and provisioning of new Kubernetes clusters,
provided you have a Kubernetes cluster.
The cluster API provides a declarative API,
just like we're used to with Kubernetes,
for managing our Kubernetes clusters.
Its responsibilities are to create and provision Kubernetes
clusters. It will handle upgrades
and day to day operations, including remediation when
required.
It is currently in an alpha state, which
means it's volatile and changing quickly,
but it doesn't mean that you can't use
it in production today.
And it is an extremely collaborative project,
with members from AWS,
DigitalOcean,
Google Cloud, Equinix Metal, and more.
Almost every cloud provider has a cluster API
provider for spinning up that next Kubernetes cluster.
Okay. So let's cover some basic capability that
you need to get started with the cluster
API.
Firstly, the documentation will make mention of a
management cluster.
This can be an existing Kubernetes cluster that
you have available within your organization,
or something as simple as Docker for Mac,
Minikube or Kind.
This cluster will run
the controllers
for creating subsequent
or target workload clusters.
The documentation will also mention infrastructure providers.
The cluster API aims to work across all
major cloud providers.
So a provider could be Google,
Amazon,
or Equinix Medal.
Perfect.
And then there's the workload cluster. Workload cluster
is the clusters that we're gonna have the
cluster API create and provision for us.
Then we have machines. These could be virtual
machines or VMs
on
AWS,
GCP,
or bare metal instances on Equinix.
We then have the concept of a machine
deployment.
This is a high level
request for the cluster API
to create one or more machines.
The machine deployment is responsible for maintaining and
creating machine sets. As we make changes to
our machine deployments,
new machine sets are created.
The machine sets are then responsible for creating
the machines.
We also have machine health checks to make
sure that the clusters and the nodes that
we provide are always healthy.
This should feel extremely familiar.
This is very similar to the resources that
we work with day in and day out
on Kubernetes,
deployments,
replica sets, pods,
and probes.
Okay.
Now that that stuff's out the way, let's
take a very brief look at how you
get started with the cluster API today.
I'm gonna quickly run through the getting started
guide from the cluster API book.
If you haven't checked out the book, I
recommend doing so as soon as possible. It
has everything you need to know about getting
started with the cluster API.
So what we have here is a very
simple Just file.
Just file is like a Makefile, but better.
It has two different targets. The first, init.
This will prepare our management cluster for creating
new Kubernetes
clusters.
Next, there's a create cluster target.
This one's a little bit more for both,
but this will generate the YAML required for
us to apply to our management cluster in
order to allow the controllers to create our
new workload
cluster. We specify the Kubernetes version that we
want, how many control plane nodes we want,
and how many worker nodes we want.
You don't have to worry about having a
single control plane node or a highly available
control plane node. Cluster API will take care
of that for you.
And in order for these just fail targets
to work, we just need a little bit
of environment information to configure it along the
way.
Of course, we need to provide an API
key for the cloud provider of choice.
Because I'm using Equinix Mineral, I also have
to provide which project to create the devices
in,
and I also have to tell it which
operating system to use for each of the
nodes as well as the facility to launch
them in.
We can configure the pod CIDR and service
CIDR for our cluster,
and we can tell it which instant types
to use
individually for the control plane node and for
any worker node pools that we have.
To get started, I can run just init.
This will
speak to my management cluster, which is Docker
for Mac.
It will install all of the custom resources
to that cluster, get the controllers running,
and pass in the packet API keys I
need for deploying new clusters on Equinix Metal.
It's called packet just because packet renamed to
Equinix Metal last year and the provider is
a little bit behind.
It's not the quickest, but it is pulling
a number of images to the management cluster.
However, that is now available for me to
generate my target cluster.
Cluster control uses templates that are baked into
each provider's repository
to try and guess what you need for
your target cluster.
And in fact, we can pop this open
in Versus Code and take a look.
Now inside of our cluster YAML, you will
see
a kubeadm control.
This is a custom resource that tells cluster
API
how to get a control plane node on
your provider of choice.
Here, we see a whole bunch of shell
commands that are required to configure the host
and install all of the Kubernetes component.
We then have a machine template
that tells us what our control plane nodes
look like.
We then have a cluster CRD that contains
each of the pod CIDR, service CIDR, and
other infrastructure parts that we need,
followed by a provider specific cluster that just
tells it the facility and project IDs.
We then have machine deployments,
more machine templates,
more QEDM configs,
and there we are. 206
lines of wonderful, beautiful YAML.
Okay. Let's get it started.
What's the problem? Seems simple enough. Right?
Unfortunately,
YAML is not the best programming language
for complex logic.
And
we seem to have got ourselves into a
bit of a pickle in the cloud native
ecosystem
when it comes to YAML. In fact, there
are memes all over the Internet
about how, you know, to be a DevOps
engineer, to be a platform engineer, to be
a Kubernetes developer
is to be a YAML developer.
And while they're funny, sometimes incorrect, and a
whole bunch of other things,
let's identify real problem that we have, that
we've gotten ourselves into. We've got Helm. We've
got Carvel. We've got Capitan. We have Customize
to help us
try and wrangle this YAML into something that
is much more fluent
to work with, that allows us to handle
complex logic and loops and
templating.
And I think it's safe to say, if
you
maintain any Helm charts, I certainly do,
it can be overwhelming
because those Helm charts which are trying to
set out a predefined way or a best
practice way for deploying a piece of software
doesn't fit everyone's use case.
People
wanna do their own thing,
and we layer and layer on more loops,
more conditionals, more loops, and more conditionals,
trying to provide enough flexibility for the end
user
while saving them time,
but at the expense of everyone's
time.
And there has to be a better way.
So I reached out to my colleague, Jason
Deceberis,
who just happens to be a contributor and
maintainer of various cluster API projects.
And
I wouldn't read
his words verbatim.
Feel free to pause and and do that
on your own accord.
But I think the message from Jason is
clear.
The cluster API's responsibility
is the reconciliation,
creation, provision, and operability
of the target clusters.
The cluster API's
responsibility is not
to provide,
you know, ergonomic tooling to generate the YAML
to describe those clusters.
And as we've seen through the Quickstart,
well, it does offer some simple mechanics to
generate that getting started
YAML.
The minute you need to be able to
make your own tweaks, things get a little
bit complicated.
You have to start copying and pasting your
own YAML to get the kind of cluster
topology that you would want or expect.
Yeah. Fine. It gives you a control plane
cluster, highly available,
but it only generates one single worker pool.
And for most production clusters, you're probably gonna
want more,
potentially within different availability zones within a single
region
with a variety of instance types, some disk
heavy, some memory heavy, some CPU heavy,
that really are tailored to your workload.
We're seeing the same confusion and complexity that
we see across broader
Kubernetes ecosystem for deployments and templating now starting
to come to the cluster API.
It is that not all clusters are the
same. And as an end user, I wanna
describe a cluster that works for me.
And for that, we need to look beyond
the cluster API
to other tools.
Okay.
Let's talk about solutions.
If we have to look beyond the cluster
API for tooling to allow us to define
the clusters that we need and we want
for our day to day lives to be
better,
then we have to look at other tooling.
Then we have to pick the right tooling,
and I am a firm believer in infrastructure
That's code.
Not as YAML.
We're using real,
high level languages that allow us to pervade
the abstractions that we need
to make our jobs almost enjoyable.
And that means that I want
something that is flexible.
I wanna be able to define a cluster
that is the size I want, that uses
the node pools I want, uses the instant
types I want, has the operating system that
I want to use because maybe there's other
things on there that I want to take
advantage of.
I think, more importantly, it also has to
be composable.
I think that we are in a stage
of Kubernetes awareness and adoption where we know
that having one giant monolithic Kubernetes cluster is
not the answer.
We actually want lots of smaller Kubernetes clusters,
and our tooling has to evolve to help
us provide that and describe that.
So when I say composable, it's like I
wanna be able to define what a node
pool looks like for machine learning workloads and
reuse that over and over again. I wanna
be able to find what a node pool
looks like
for databases, for stateful workloads,
for disk IOPS are critical
and security across the board.
And it has to be ergonomic.
I have to enjoy
using it.
Coding doesn't have to be a chore.
We provide abstractions and libraries to make our
lives easier.
I wanna make future me life easier,
and there is a way.
So,
the solution I'm gonna show today is based
on a project called Pulumi, which hopefully you're
aware of. It is an infrastructure as code
tool.
It allows you, the developer, to make your
own choices.
You wanna write your infrastructure as code in
Python,
Go,
JavaScript, TypeScript,
.net.
These are all choices you do get to
make.
Pulumi allows you
and provides an SDK
to work with a language that you're more
comfortable with.
And what we have here is an example
of using the TypeScript SDK for Azure
to spin up an app service,
which has a handler, an anonymous function, my
business logic can go there,
and then just four lines of code to
describe how to deploy that to the Azure
ecosystem.
These are the ergonomics that we're talking about.
Less than 10 lines of code, easy to
read, easy to reason, easy to change.
It's very explicit and does only what I
need.
There's another project from the Pulumi Corporation
that allows us to generate
these types
from the custom resource definitions that are widely
available in the Kubernetes ecosystem.
By not confined
to v one or apps v one,
they're already broadly known and understood,
but to any custom resource that is online
that has an open API specification as part
of its resource.
Pulumi can generate the types and allow us
to consume them using the same ergonomics that
we're becoming accustomed to.
As I said, Pulumi supports the languages you're
already familiar with. I'm a big fan of
using TypeScript. I think it works really well
for infrastructure as code with a strongly typed
but dynamic nature.
However, this is cloud native. Go is an
option as long as you don't mind checking
for errors every thirteen seconds.
Python and .net are also available, and more
languages I've heard are coming soon.
And there's one secret thing that launched very
recently from the Pulumi Corporation,
And it's that they have enabled cross language
SDK runtime capability.
Meaning,
I like TypeScript.
I publish libraries in TypeScript.
You let go. You want to write your
infrastructure's code in Go.
You can now consume TypeScript libraries from Go
as I can consume the type the Go
library
from TypeScript.
Wow.
So for the rest of this talk, we're
gonna be moving into the live demo where
I will show you the library that I've
built and how it allows you to define
Kubernetes clusters with great ergonomics, composability,
and extremely flexible.
Okay. Let's take a look.
So what I have here is a brand
new Pulumi project inside of my KubeCon directory.
It's configured for Kubernetes and TypeScript,
which means that it comes with the Pulumi
SDK, Kubernetes SDK, and some Kubernetes helpers.
In my own namespace, I have access to
all of the cluster API resources that have
already generated and published.
First thing I'm gonna do is just pull
in the cluster API generic package.
From here, we can open our index dot
TypeScript,
and we wanna import
star as copy
from
our new library.
Now one of the more
difficult things to automate with the cluster API
is that initial infrastructure
provision,
because the only way to do it is
through a cluster control in it dash dash
infrastructure
packet.
It then requires a secret to exist in
the environment
that tells the controllers how to speak to
the cloud provider.
Cluster control does not provide a way
to generate the YAML and store that for
a GitOps fashion.
However, the library I provided
does ship with helpers to initialize your provider
in your management cluster.
So the first thing we wanna do is
initialize the cluster API.
And we can do we can do that
through
a call to edit.
Now
one of the really nice things about working
with TypeScript
is that you don't need to know the
SDKs upfront
because the language server protocols are all really,
really good.
And in fact, I can just type copy
dot,
and already I can see the API space
that is available for me to use.
Now I'm not quite ready to create a
cluster.
I'm just gonna do init,
and I don't know what parameters this function
takes.
But I open my parameters, and I can
see, oh,
the inner function takes a cluster API
config.
Do
we know what a cluster API config is?
Well,
not yet.
But we can expand that, use our autocomplete,
and we can see, oh, it wants to
know whether we should install cert manager,
and if so, which version.
It also wants to know whether we want
to enable any of the feature.
And finally, it needs a Kubernetes provider.
So let's just quickly run through this one
by one.
When we did the cluster control in it
earlier, we did see that it installed cert
manager. In fact, it's required.
So
I'm just gonna say true. Yeah. Why not
install cert manager?
What version?
Well,
I already know that one one zero is
available, so I'm just gonna drop that straight
in. But you could find that from the
cost from the SERP manager GitHub repository.
Next.
Oh, feature case. Well,
we can hover over, and we know that
it expects a list of something called a
feature gate. So let's just pop open our
list and
click on feature gate, and we can see
there's two features available for us to enable.
We don't need to know what our machine
pool is yet, but I am gonna enable
cluster resource set.
Cluster resource sets are a way for you
to define manifest
to deploy to your new target clusters or
workload clusters when they become available.
It kinda like GitOps.
And finally, we need a Kubernetes
provider.
I'm gonna leave this blank for just a
moment.
And that's it.
That will enable the cluster API controllers on
my management cluster.
However,
I've not provided the dash dash infrastructure provider
yet.
Let's do that next.
So we're going to pull in one more
import.
We have to go to our package dot
JSON
and add one more package.
This time, I'm gonna add the packet
provider.
We can run a yarn install,
and that'll just take a moment.
Okay. Now we can come back and complete
this.
We're gonna pull in the packet provider.
Again, we don't know the API upfront,
but we can say packet copy equals
cap dot.
And again, we have the ability to create
a control plane or initialize the management cluster.
Just like before, it needs a config.
Okay. So let's take care of that API
key first.
One of the really great things about using
Pulumi for infrastructure as code is in built
secret management.
That means I can just see blank strength
for now, jump up to the top of
my file and import
the Pulumi
library.
From here,
I can create a new config object. I'm
gonna call this the config metal,
which is a new Pulumi
config
with a prefix of Equinix
metal.
I can then say here, config metal
dot require
secret
auth
token.
And that's it.
What's actually happening here is that our Pulumi
stack is configured with a secret provider.
That can be a cloud KMS from AWS,
GCP, or anywhere else,
or it can be a password protected local
provider.
I can open the Pulumi production environment, and
we see a prefix of Equinix metal, and
we see a key of off token.
And here, we have an encrypted version of
our API token,
which is all that has been consumed here.
Next, we need a cluster API.
What is that? Well, we can hover over
and see that it's just looking
for some providers that come from our CAPI
in it. Our copy in it actually returns
a set of manifest.
So from here, we can see cluster API
dot cluster API.
And finally, there is a Kubernetes
provider.
We ignored that above, but we're gonna take
care of it now.
So all we need to do is create
a new Kubernetes
provider.
For that, we import the Kubernetes
package,
And we can create a new, okay,
dot
provider.
We can see here
that it needs a name.
We'll just call this local.
Now we can add our Kubernetes provider
to both
of our innits,
and that is it.
Now we can run this Pulumi program
to provision cluster API controllers
to a Kubernetes cluster.
So, of course, I won't make you take
my word for it.
Let's actually run this.
We'll pop over here,
jump to the terminal, and we're gonna run
Lumi
app.
It's gonna work out from those functions that
we provided, which resource have to be created
within the management cluster. You can see there's
a fair few.
We can hit yes
and give it just a few moments,
and it will begin applying these
to the cluster.
Now
one of the things that Pulumi does is
try to ensure that what we apply will
actually become healthy.
That means that it's probably gonna sit there
for quite a while while it waits to
make sure that the deployments and the images
are pulled, the pods are passing all the
probes, the services have endpoints,
all of those little bits and pieces that
normally we just allow the Kubernetes reconciliation loop
to take care of.
So I'm just gonna click control c
couple of times.
And I'm gonna run get pods all.
Maybe. There we go.
We'll see we have cert manager,
and we have our CAPI controllers, and we
even have the packet controller manager.
Not quite ready yet,
but getting there.
And I control c that because I've not
fussed about it at a finish. I wanna
show you an alternative approach that may better
fit your workflow.
Okay. So let's jump back into our code.
And where we created our Kubernetes provider,
we're gonna make a few small tweaks.
We're gonna open up the arguments,
and we're gonna see that we have a
bunch of things that we can tweak with
a Kubernetes provider.
For one, it doesn't have to use whichever
context is available to me in the environment.
I can provide my own KubeConfig.
I can specify a namespace that I wanna
deploy to,
or
I can render YAML.
We can see
rendered YAML.
Now we can come to the command lane
and run Pulumi up.
And instead of reaching out to that cluster,
checking which resources exist,
waiting for health checks and services and add
endpoints and liveness probes to pass,
we can just click yes and allow Pulumi
to write a bunch of YAML
to a directory
that we can apply whenever we want.
Just that simple.
And that's it.
We can pop open Versus Code. We'll see
this brand new render YAML directory.
We can see the CRDs that need to
be applied to the cluster,
as well as all of the manifests with
all of the resources
that have to exist.
And that's not all. It was just the
beginning.
As well as installing
cluster API as the providers to our cluster,
we can add and layer on more abstractions
to make our lives easier. You can see
that there's already the ability to create a
control plane
on an Equinix Mineral cluster
that has the configuration options that an Equinix
Mineral customer would come to expect.
The project ID, the number of replicas, the
machine types, the facility, and the image.
And, of course, it's not Equinix Mineral specific.
And in fact, we can take a look
at CAPD,
which is the Digital Ocean provider. Again, using
just a simple edit command
and a config,
we can provide the access token, the cluster
API manifest, and the Kubernetes provider just like
we did earlier
to make Digital Ocean Kubernetes clusters available to
us on our management cluster.
There's no reason we can't support AWS,
GCP,
and all the other major cloud providers.
It just requires a little bit of effort
to put together these abstractions.
Okay.
Let's head back to the slides.
So what's coming next?
Well,
the CDK8s is a really, really cool project.
It's it's very similar
to Pulumi in that it exposes a multi
language or runtime for defining and creating Kubernetes
resources.
Generating the types is actually a lot easier
with CDK's than it is in Pulumi. It
doesn't require an external command,
but there are some trade offs from both
approaches.
As we've seen with Pulumi, we can use
Pulumi's runtime to speak to the Kubernetes cluster
and do the apply.
This allows us to take advantage of Pulumi's
inbuilt secrets management.
This protects
our access tokens and API keys from being
rendered to YAML and available even ephemerally
in some location.
And c d case doesn't have that, just
as Pulumi doesn't have it when we render
to YAML too.
So it could be a good idea to
install and edit
the cluster API and the providers via Pulumi,
but then use c d kits and Pulumi's
abstractions to generate the YAML to define each
unique cluster.
That's up to you.
And I'd like to see more use of
Open Policy Agent for testing
the clusters that we are creating.
The Pulumi SDK that I provided
applies some basic tests to ensure
that all of the feature gates are interpolated
before they hit your management cluster.
But there's a lot more that we can
do there too.
And I'd like to see more providers. I'd
like types generated for AWS
and for GCP
and maybe even Oracle Cloud. Who knows?
And I think what we really need
is more abstractions,
more helper functions to create
unique
cluster configurations
for machine learning, for computer intensive workloads, for
stateful workloads,
more abstractions and higher level functions that can
make all of our lives easier.
One of the really cool things about cluster
API is cluster resources.
The ability in the management cluster to see
when we have a new healthy cluster created,
we should go and apply a set of
resources.
These are a little finicky to work with
because you have to actually encapsulate
the deployments, services, the conflict maps, the secrets
for those individual workloads into a config map
itself.
And this is exactly where abstractions like this
can make our lives easier.
So that's my talk.
I hope I've given you some food for
thought.
Not only does the tooling that I've shown
today for cluster API
exist and can better our lives,
but it's not confined to cluster API either.
There's no reason we can't use CDK and
Pulumi across our entire deployment surface for Kubernetes.
But there's still a lot to be done,
a lot of challenges to solve,
and a lot of things we can make
simpler.
I can't wait to see what you do
with it.
Best of luck. Have a great day.